le groupe c le rythme on l'a dans la
peau
c'est puissant c'est sale et pourris
vous le définir avec exactitude
j'ai été très clair je vous dise un truc
important sur pièce moi je les suis le
jour de ma naissance tout le monde
connaîtra mono n'abandonne jamais si tu
penses tu fait marche arrière
ils veulent que les rolling stones
permis le show j'avance je contrôle je
change la donne
les rolling stones sans jamais faire
djiby sy je sais jagger keith richards
il y en avait récolté au triplé qui
triment si vous voulez explosé moi j'ai
explosé un peu plus tous les jours
ouvrés grand vos oreilles
ce type est un génie maj tous la tête
grâce à james brown toile se serait
passé ça marche pas musicalement est-ce
que ça sonne bien
est ce que ça donne bah si ça sonne bien
que ça donne bien ces musicales alors
faut le jouer comme j'ai dit monsieur le
président je veux aller au vietnam le
meilleur pour qu'on a peur du grand
méchant enfin que ces panneaux kaya sur
le prof on nous tire dessus
désolé pour vous ceux ci d'avion ceci
d'ailleurs on a essayé de tuer john
foire d'aujourd'hui vous l'êtes connu
comme l'homme qui a tué les cinq
suivants dr king le maire de boston a
annulé le concert de demain soir le seul
mais à la communauté noire m'écoute
vous aurez au choix 10 mille personnes
en colère dans le boston garden ou dix
mille personnes en colère dans votre
jardin aux démunis ou pas
et ont vu empêcher les meutes ils ont
peur que tu provoques unis après tout ce
que j'ai fait le conflit
this attack adjoint
mon dieu c'est à jamais de la terre
comment tu saura trouver une dernière
question quel est votre plat favori
hobby explique la dame blanche qu'on
mange